thank you very much for joining this
presentation
my name is marca from liteswag i'm an
assistant professor of neuroscience at
mayo clinic jacksonville
today i will talk to you about how
targeted long reach sequencing methods
can be used
to assess an expanded repeat in a gene
called c9 or
72 by the end of this presentation you
should be familiar with
methods that can be used to size and
detect
c9 of 72 repeat expansions moreover you
should understand
that targeted long read sequencing can
accurately measure the length of the
expansion
as well as the presence of interruptions
a repeat expansion in c9 or 72
is associated with two fatal
neurodegenerative diseases
namely ftd frontal temporal dementia
and als amyotrophic lateral sclerosis
ftd is the second most common cause of
dementia in individuals below 65 years
of age
it affects neurons in the frontal and
temporal cortex
causing changes in behavior personality
and language impairment
patients often die within 7 to 11 years
after the onset of symptoms
als is the most common form of motor
neurone disease
it results in degeneration of upper and
lower motor neurons in the brain
and spinal cord this results in
progressive muscle weakness
and spasticity affecting the arms leg
and trunk
but also muscles involved in speech
swallowing and breathing
consequently patients with als often die
within three to seven years after the
onset of symptoms
due to respiratory failure
there is considerable clinical genetic
and pathological overlap between
ftd and als and today i will focus on
the genetic
overlap in 2011 two papers were
published in neuron
one study led by a doctor jose
rademachers
and another study led by dr brian
traynor
both these studies reported c9 or 72
repeat expansions
and it turns out that they are actually
the most common genetic calls
of both ftd and als this major discovery
was made
roughly a decade ago regardless many
questions remain
unanswered we do know however that there
is a lot of variability
variability in the age at onset survival
after onset
disease symptoms even within families
some individuals may develop ftd other
individuals
als or a combination of both diseases
the repeat itself contains six
nucleotides
four g's and two c's it's a
hexanucleotide repeat
and in the general population people
often carry maybe
two repeats five repeats eight repeats a
little bit more
that's all within the normal range
patients with ftd or als however can
harbor
hundreds to thousands of repeats and
this has major consequences
it for instance reduces the expression
levels of c9 or 72
it also results in the formation of rna
foci that contain
flawed rnas trapping rna binding
proteins
and resulting in hampering while
basically hampering the function of
these proteins
we can also see that peptide repeat
proteins
and this is really interesting because
you think about
it this expansion is located in a
non-coding area
it should not be translated into a
protein
but it is and that's due to a process
called repeat associated
non-atg translation and the two most
abundant dipeptide repeat proteins
are polyga and polygp
and today i will cover two topics the
length of the c9472 expansion
and the presence of interruptions but
before we discuss
that i think it's important to know more
about detection methods for this c dinor
72 repeat expansion
so in my lab we generally use a two-step
protocol
we start with a fluorescent pcr a
fragment length analysis
that allows you to determine the length
of the wild-type
allele if you see two peaks then you
know that this individual is
heterozygous
and has basically two wild-type alleles
maybe
two repeats on one allele and five
repeats on another allele
when you see a single peak it's more
challenging to interpret the results
because there could be multiple
explanations it's possible that this
person carries two repeats on one allele
and two repeats on the other allele
but it's also possible that this person
carries two repeats on one allele
and a very long expansion on the other
allele making it
impossible to detect it using a
fluorescent pcr
thus the next step is a repeat primed
pcr
a reaction with three primers two
primers on both sides of the repeat
and a primer that targets the repeat
itself
if an expansion is present then you see
this characteristic stutter pattern
as shown here on this slide without this
expansion
no such pattern is observed and this is
really a diagnostic
test but if you want to be 100 sure
that the expansion is present or absent
you should do a southern blot
the gold standard on this slide on the
right you can see an example of a
southern blot
the expansion is the top bend and the
wild type allele the bottom
bend and in this case we're displaying
three individuals three unique
individuals
and two regions for each individual the
frontal cortex
and the cerebellum and as you may see
there is a significant difference in the
repeat length
the repeat length is significantly
higher in the frontal cortex
than in the cerebellum furthermore there
is variability within
each region you can see that there is a
smear it's not
one nice concise bend there is
variability so
it's important to realize that there is
variability across
tissues as well as within tissues
now i would also like to stress that a
southern blood is actually very
challenging and time consuming it takes
roughly a week
to do one southern blot now consequently
people have been considering
using other methods and i'm showing a
couple of examples here on this slide
in 2017 a paper was published where they
developed
a new tool called expansion hunter that
allows the detection of repeat
expansions including a c9 of 72 repeat
expansion
and pcr free short short-read whole
genome sequencing data
they examined more than 3 000 als
patients
and detecting the expansion in roughly
200
and all their patients they detected
were correctly identified so that was
very reassuring at the same time because
they were using short read sequencing
data
it is very difficult to reconstruct the
expansion itself
so you could consider using other
methods and two examples of more read
sequencing techniques
are shown here on the right and in the
bottom
a paper published in 2018 and another
paper published in 2019
and one of these studies the first study
was led by my colleague dr ebert
and they used various technologies and
different platforms
oxford nanopore technologies ont and
pegbio pacific biosciences and they also
used
various strategies a whole genome
sequencing strategy
as well as a targeted strategy using
crispr-based methods
um to really focus on the area of
interest
and these studies were proof of concept
studies but the findings were very
promising and therefore
we decided to look at a larger number of
individuals and we used one specific
technique
no m sequencing developed by pec bio
for this study we investigated 28 well
characterized c9 of 72 expansion
carriers
and their characteristics are shown in
the table on the left
as you can see 50 female and h onset
around 63 years
and we obtained a lot of detailed
information
information about the expression levels
of c9 of 72
about the methylation levels of the c9
of 72 promoter
about the levels of dipeptide repeat
proteins
rna fosan and the repeat length based on
southern blood estimates
we extracted high molecular weight
genomic dna
from the cerebellum using the recovery
skid from agilent
and up to 10 microgram of dna was used
for each sample
on one smart cell on the sequel 2
platform
and we used as i mentioned crispr cast 9
based method
to excise the area of interest we also
used a 1 hour extension
4 hour immobilization and a 30 hour
movie time and here you can see an
overview of our bioinformatics approach
you can see that we used pegbios
pipeline with modifications for long
repeats
and i don't know how familiar you are
with circular consensus sequencing leads
ccs reads
basically our idea is that you sequence
the same piece over and over again
and because you do that you increase the
accuracy of your reads
and we said well basically we need two
things we need to look at the length of
the repeat expansion
but we also want to look at the presence
of interruptions and therefore we used
two
different strategies a standard strategy
where we said okay we want to keep all
the reads with at least
one full pass spanning the entire
expansion and an accuracy of 80
or more and on top of that we want to do
a more stringent analysis
high quality reads with at least seven
passes
and an accuracy of 99 or more
we then aligned the reads to the human
reference genome
h238 and we used the clustering method
to distinguish the wild type allele from
the expanded allele
and of course we made sure that we
included the flanking regions because we
really wanted to focus on those reads
that spanned the entire expansion
and here you can see an example of one
individual
and for this individual more than 250
ccs reads were obtained and as you can
see there is a nice peak
that refers to the c9 or 72 locus
so we have in on target reads as
expected
we've also visualized it in igv as you
can see on this slide
with forward reads reverse reads and
then an insertion shown in purple
and the number of nucleotides is
specified in white i know that it's
difficult to see but
what's more important is that this
figure also
specifies the region and it's the region
we're interested in
it's indeed the ci north 72 gene and the
inter in the
insertion the c9 or 72 expansion itself
is indeed present in either the first
entrance or the promoter region
as whether it should be basically
then we looked at the distribution of
the reads and we were able to obtain
more than
3 500 ccs reads in total or individuals
combined
including more than our almost 2700
reads for the wild type reveal
and more than 800 for the expenditure
and subsequently we said okay let's look
at the link let's look at the length
of the wild hyperlink and it varied
between two weeks
two repeats and 11 repeats and that's
correct because we were able to compare
it to the results of our fluorescent pcr
we then looked at the expansion and the
expansion size varied
from roughly 3 kb to more than 20 kb
and basically 500 repeats up to 3 500
repeats
a histogram is shown on the left and in
this histogram you can see the frequency
and you can see the number of repeats
and the dashed line
indicates the median of the samples we
investigated
and the median was 1261 rupees so almost
8 kb you can see on this slide that
there was a lot of variability between
the individuals we investigated every
single individual is displayed
individual 1 to 28 and then we've
specified the number of reads for each
given individual in each bar
and as you can see it varies from joints
to
almost 100 reads in the next few slides
i will provide a potential explanation
about this that may explain this
potential variability between these
samples
okay so on this slide you can see some
extreme cases
we looked at our southern blot results
and we selected an individual with a
relatively small expansion
and an individual with a relatively long
expansion in the cerebellum
and then we looked at their no m
sequencing results
and as you can see the individual with a
small expansion is shown in light blue
and the individual with the long
expansion in dark blue and clearly were
able to pick up
this important difference so that's very
reassuring
we then visualized it in a correlation
plot as shown on this slide
where we've included the number of
repeats based on nom sequencing
as well as the number of repeats based
on sudden blotting
every single individual is represented
by a dot and the linear regression line
is included as well
and as you can see there is a positive
correlation when the southern blood
estimates increase the no m sequencing
estimates increase
as well and you may notice the different
colors
that we're using red orange and
yellow indicate a relatively high number
of reeds and what's interesting
is that people with a relatively high
number of reeds are all located in the
bottom left corner
suggesting that people with a smaller
expansion
actually have a higher number of reads
and that is confirmed here in this plot
of booksplot
where the median is specified with a
dark a horizontal line and the box
blends
the 25th percentile to the 75th
percentile and we split
every one we split everyone based on the
median so in light blue you can see
people with a relatively small expansion
the bottom 50 and in dark blue people
with a relatively
long expansion are top fifty percent and
clearly the people with a relatively
small expansion
appear to have the highest number of
reads we also noticed something else
when we compare the actual length
between
southern blotting and no end sequencing
there was a significant difference
and you can see on this slide that there
was much more variability based on sun
and blotting
than on nom sequencing and the estimates
also appear to be
lower using nom sequencing so yes
there is a significant association
between nom sequencing and southern
blotting
but no amp sequencing has a tendency to
underestimate
the size we then wondered okay now we've
basically validated
this method um but is it relevant does
it
matter what the expansion size in the
cerebellum is
and you can see here that yes it does
matter
and this is a survival curve captain
meyer curve and
i should stress that as you know the
survival differs depending on whether
you're looking at patients with ftd
or patients with als so we've adjusted
for the disease subgroup
in our model and on this slide
individuals with relatively small
expansions the bottom 50 are shown in
light blue
and again people with relatively long
expansions
dark blue the top 50 and there is a
significant difference
the survival is 4.9 years for people
with a small expansion
and 1.8 years for people with a long
expansion
and that indicates that it might be
beneficial to have a small
expansion we also spotted something else
which is specified here
we looked at the number of repeats and
one specific transcript the relative
expression levels of entering on b
containing transcripts and i don't know
how familiar you are with these
transcripts for c9 of 72 but there are
basically
three well-known transcript parent 1
variant 2 and variant 3
but it's also important to look at
intran-containing transcripts and that's
what we're doing here
we're looking at entrant 1b which is
located after the expansion
downstream and it's basically a
surrogate marker for transcripts that
contain
the expansion and on this night i'm
showing that
as the number of repeats decreases the
expression levels of these expansion
containing transcripts go up
and that does make sense because it
suggests that if you have a small
expansion it might be easier to
transcribe it
resulting in higher levels of
transcripts that contain
the expansion we then looked at the
peptide repeat protein levels and here
again we're displaying two plots
with the number of repeats and in this
case the burden of their peptide repeat
proteins
specifically polytp and polyta
and a similar inverse correlation is
seen as the number of repeat decreases
the burden of that peptide repeat
proteins goes up
and this does make sense as well because
i just told you
that if you have a smaller expansion
it's easier to transcribe it
they have higher levels of expansion
containing transcripts
and these expansion-containing
transcripts serve as templates for
repeat associated non-atg translation
run translation therefore causing higher
levels
of dipeptide repeat proteins as well
so the next topic i would like to cover
today
are interruptions and interruptions are
known to hectares disease modifiers in
other repeat expansion disorders
but we know very little about the purity
of the c9 of 72 repeat expansion
so to this end we restricted our
analysis to high quality reads with at
least seven passes
an accuracy of 99 or more
we had 2500 high quality ccs beads in
total
all samples combined including more than
2 300 for the wild type review
and more than 200 for the expansion and
as you know we're looking at a c9 north
72
expansion with four g's and two c's
so if it's relatively pure you expect to
see a very high jc
content and that's exactly what we saw
in this plot
every single individual is displayed and
the bar
represents the percentage gc and
as you can see it's roughly 100 for
every single individual so the gc
content
is very high a's and t's are only
occasionally
encountered we then looked at the
expansion itself
and you can see that here the gtg cc
repeat and again every single individual
is included individual 1 to 28 but this
time
the bar represents the percentage gggcc
and it's not 100 it's not but it's
pretty close it's actually 96
so that seems to indicate that the
expansion is
relatively pure and that interruptions
at least in the cerebellum of these
individuals
account for less than five or four
percent
of the expansion you can also visualize
it using a waterfall plot
and this is a waterfall plot from one
particular individual
with more than 20 ccs reads which are
shown on the
y-axis and on the x-axis you can see the
position of the nucleotides
if the gttg repeat is present the
hexanucleotide repeat we're interested
in
it's blue if another sequence is present
another motif
it's displayed in gray now you do see
some green lines but not that many
and they appear to occur at random
positions there is no clear pattern
and you can see a similar phenomenon
here similar pattern
for another individual so this is an
individual with 12
high quality ccs reads and the position
of the
is specified and again a lot of blue
and you do see a couple of other colors
in this case we specified other motifs
using different colors
the most common alternative motif is a
motive
with three g's and two c's
now based on the plots i've showed you
and the bar graphs
we said okay well every once in a while
we see interruptions
not very often but they are completely
random
so maybe they're not real maybe they
actually represent where
sequencing errors and that's not
surprising given the gc
content the length of the expansion and
its repetitiveness
so we think it's actually quite likely
that they represent
rare sequencing errors
so what have i shared with you today
well
hopefully i've convinced you that no mc9
or 72 sequencing
can spend the entire repeat expansion
that repeat lengths based on nom
sequencing correlate with those obtained
using sun and blotting but
that there appears to be a bias towards
smaller expansions
and that the sizes might be
underestimated
i've also demonstrated that smaller
expansions are associated with prolonged
survival with
higher levels of expansion containing
transcripts and with higher levels of
dipeptide repeat proteins
moreover the expansion has a high gc
content
and appears to be relatively pure thus
low amp sequencing is a powerful tool
and it has
the ability to reveal relevant clinical
pathological associations
for senior north 72 related disorders
it actually stresses the important role
of the cerebellar expansion size in
these fatal neural degenerative diseases
i'd like to thank all my lab members
particularly maria de jesus hernandez
as well as my colleagues at mayo clinic
florida minnesota
arizona um my colleague mark ebbert
who spearheaded this research are
clinicians
who have collected all these precious
samples our genome analysis course
led by dr wieben ross for generating
all this no m sequencing data pegbio for
their advice and guidance
the muscular dystrophy association mda
for funding this specific project le
boots
for hosting this webinar and of course i
would like to thank you for watching
this video
hopefully you've enjoyed watching it
thank you very much
bye
[Music]
okay very well done awesome job
um well pretty much from here we'll just
do some
quick editing on the front and back ends
since there was no interruptions during
your presentation
and then we'll have it ready for the
event in just a few weeks
that's good but few weeks they said i
thought it was like
um september 30th right i think that's
the
actual event yes yes the 30th so i guess
about a week and a half or so yeah yeah
because you were saying a few weeks i
think that gold
but was everything clear and easy to
understand
yeah i thought you did a good job at uh
clearly communicating and it went very
smoothly
and again i'll send you the preview link
so you can let me know your thoughts
if you feel that it's necessary to do
any kind of re-recording that's
definitely an option so we can do that
if
uh you think that that needs to be
i think it's fine i i don't really it's
always hard to predict right but because
i haven't listened to my own
presentation
yet but there were a few instances where
i
stumbled a little bit it was like oh oh
oh and i changed it a little bit but i
think i corrected everything
um it should be fine probably and i
don't know about other people
as i said i haven't really done this
before and you're recording something
um so i don't know if
yeah how this compares to what other
people do that's hard for me to guess
i don't know no and i know definitely
different uh presenting to a webcam
versus an audience
that you can't read so it definitely has
some challenges but i thought you did a
great job with uh
with doing so great okay
is there anything else i need to know or
need to do
um i'm just going to check in and make
sure that we have
all of the info that we need from you
and it looks like
we do have all of your abstract and
learning objectives so we're all set
there
if anything comes up i will let you know
if not i'll send that link over to you
when it's ready
and if you have questions at all feel
free to reach out to me
okay good well thank you so much for
your help today thank you
have a good rest of your day and how do
i close this do i need to do something
specific or can i just close the wing no
um you can close it i'm also going to
end the
recording now and it will automatically
close your window out
okay good well thank you so much again
thank you everybody
bye